>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Peter Nelson: My name's
Peter Nelson, I'm the Director
of Research and Innovation
for ServeMinnesota.
And we're very thankful and
happy today to be here today
to talk a little bit
about Reading Corps.
So, at its heart, Reading Corps
is a tutoring program designed
to increase the number
of students
who are reading proficiently
by third grade.
And I think as everyone
here knows,
that outcome is particularly
important not just
for what it is, but for
what it represents in terms
of students' academic trajectory
and their career trajectory.
But also, knowing that the
benefits to individuals
who are reading early and
developing those skills early,
extend to society as well.
So, as the name suggests,
Reading Corps is
fueled by AmeriCorps.
And I want to put my
researcher cap on for a second
to highlight how
exciting that is.
Because essentially,
there is all this research
that's happening.
Academic institutions
that might be compiled
in best practice
guides, and be published
in peer review journals.
And by in large, all this
information is not translating
very well, the practice
taking a very long time.
And then, you have all these
folks who are highly passionate
about reading that are
compassionate about service.
And you know, wouldn't it be
great if we could marry the two?
And this is the opportunity
that AmeriCorps affords us,
and at ServeMinnesota
it's something
that we really take to heart.
We think about AmeriCorps
as an opportunity
to reach our communities,
but do it in a way
that helps bridge the gap
between research and practice.
So, in -- well, I'll just say,
in the context of reading,
what this looks like is that
our tutors, what they're doing
in the schools is all directly
connected to empirical research.
They're using data every
day to make decisions,
and there are structures
in place to ensure
that what's happening
in practice aligns
with how we talk
about the program.
So, the program spans
from Pre-K to third grade,
and the only difference
between the two --
so, in K-3 they're full time
AmeriCorps members working
in the school.
And they're doing
pull-out intervention,
so each kid gets 20
minutes a day, every day,
targeted reading intervention.
In Pre-K, that's happening,
but the member's also pushing
into the core instruction
environment.
So, they're partnering
with the preschool teacher
to deliver whole class
literacy intervention.
As well as just, engaging in a
number of different activities
to increase the quality of
the instructional environment.
So, I mentioned implementation
integrity.
Another thing that's
a little unique
about Reading Corps is that, we
have an Internal Coach first.
And that person is there to
really help the member feel
like they're a part of
the school community.
Because we know that members
who feel like they are a part
of the school community
are going
to have a more meaningful
experience
in their service here.
That they're going
to be happier,
and that they're going
to be more impactful.
This is something that
we've seen sort of,
born out through data as well.
And then, we also have
Master Coaches who serve
as content experts, so
they serve as consultants
to Internal Coaches, and as
-- also to the tutors as well.
So, does this program work?
In a word, yes, it does.
So, these are just some data
from a recent evaluation done
by NORC at the University
of Chicago.
And this is Pre-K, and the
gold bars, you're looking
at performance of kids who
receive reading course support.
And the grey bars, those
are the comparison students,
so equivalent type students.
You can see, you know,
across these Pre-K outcomes,
students who receive Reading
Corps tend to do better
than students who didn't.
And what's exciting, for us,
is that we see these outcomes
every year in our sort of,
annual evaluation data, and
we see them across grades.
We also see it across
gender, ethnicity,
English Learner status,
we see these effects
across these categories.
And we can look at
geographic regions as well,
so within the state
of Minnesota.
We look at rural areas,
they're sort of larger areas
like St. Cloud or Rochester,
but also the urban areas
of Minneapolis and St. Paul,
where a large percentage
of the students who
are meeting proficiency
by third grade were
served by Reading Corps.
And we look at states
where we're expanding in to
where a larger percentage
of the students are
exceeding benchmark growth.
Which is important,
because you know,
these students are
starting here, you can kind
of visually see they need to
exceed expected rates of growth
in order to catch
up to their peers.
And also, just noting that these
outcomes, I mentioned earlier,
they matter for the individuals,
but they matter for schools.
they matter for states, and they
matter for the nation in terms
of -- and they have
real fiscal value.
and reading has a
monetary benefit.
So, the last thing I want to
talk about is related to our,
again, I'm in research.
So, we have a Research
and Development crew
that's really tasked
with something I think,
I'm willing to bet
of us grapple with, which
is, you design a program,
you find out it's
effective, and then,
you know, you say, now what?
Well, under what conditions is
it most effective and where?
And also, thinking about,
well, how can we get better?
How can we continue to innovate?
Because you can't just continue
to exist the way you are.
You're always thinking
about getting better.
So, we look at adding
programs related to vocabulary.
We look at areas that are in
areas of concentrated poverty,
and say, well, can we
do something different
in these schools?
And again, all of this really
toward the end of trying
to just figure a little bit more
about the program, and figuring
out ways to improve
both the efficiency
and the effectiveness.
So, that's it, I had a really
great time so far hearing
about all the programs.
I'm excited to hear about some
of our colleagues in tutoring,
and thank you very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.